una función fx esta gráfica da abajo
resalta un intervalo donde la función f
x sea mayor que 0 y su derivada f prima
de x sea menor que 0 muy bien entonces
que sea positiva la función sea positiva
quiere decir que está por arriba de este
eje
entonces si nos damos cuenta podemos
movernos durante digamos en todo este
espacio hasta aquí porque ya después se
vuelve negativa y luego podemos volver a
elegir de este lado muy bien pero además
tenemos que ser un poco más selectivos
porque me pide que la primera derivada
la derivada de la función sea negativa
eso quiere decir que la función de
crezca verdad entonces fíjense si nos
ponemos más o menos en esta zona digamos
y nos ponemos en esta zona sí es cierto
que la función es positiva sin embargo
la función va creciendo a medida que que
x se va moviendo hacia la derecha
entonces toda esta zona no la podemos
elegir acá por ejemplo tenemos que la
función es positiva y ahora la función
va de cree
siendo va creciendo cada vez me bueno va
haciéndose cada vez más pequeña va
decreciendo muy bien y eso pasa hasta
aquí después se vuelve negativo y de
este otro lado ya no podemos porque aquí
la función crece y lo que sí sabemos es
que cuando la función tiene una derivada
negativa eso quiere decir que la
pendiente de la recta tangente es menor
que 0 entonces quiere decir que la
función decrece así que de todas estas
opciones por acá es una buena opción y
vamos a comprobar que esto es cierto muy
bien vamos a hacer otro dice una función
f x esta gráfica da abajo resalta un
intervalo donde la función sea positiva
y su primera derivada sea positiva así
que nuevamente buscamos un intervalo en
donde la función esté por arriba del eje
así que sólo puede estar por aquí verdad
sólo podemos andar moviéndonos por aquí
pero además nos piden que la derivada
sea positiva quiere decir que la función
crece entonces por aquí es una buena
opción porque aquí la función va
haciéndose cada vez más grande sin
embargo acá la función se va haciendo
más chica entonces elegimos este
intervalo y lo tuvimos correcto vamos a
hacer un último dice una función f x
esta gráfica ábaco resalta un intervalo
donde la función sea negativa y su
primera derivada es positiva entonces
ahora ya no nos interesa estos porque
queremos que la función sea negativa ni
tampoco por acá lo queremos solo en este
pedazo solo en ese pedazo de aquí ahora
hay que ver cuando la función crece
porque la función tiene derivada
positiva entonces aquí vamos decreciendo
hasta que llegamos a este punto y ahora
seguimos creciendo entonces si lo
dejamos por aquí vamos a tener que
resolver bien el ejercicio y en efecto
lo obtuvimos bien una vez más